[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
guten Abend schön dass Sie dabei sind
wie auch Christian Otto für den Sport ja
hallo und guten Abend schauen wir auf
die Themen von heute
wie grün ist die Ampel wärmewende
heizungsgesetz und Klimaziele Parteichef
auch mit Nuri pur im ZDF sommerinterview
Europa und die Migration die EU und
Tunesien verständigen sich auf ein
Abkommen wenige Flüchtlinge gegen mehr
Geld
und freiwasserschwimmer glänzen bei WM
Florian Wellbrock holt Gold Oliver
klimat schwimmt zu Bronze
[Musik]
bald ist Halbzeit der Ampelkoalition
seit gut eineinhalb Jahren regieren SPD
FDP und Grüne
54% der Befragten im jüngsten
Politbarometer meinen sie tun das eher
schlecht vor allem die Grünen mussten
Federn lassen keine andere Partei hat
seit dem letzten Sommer in den Umfragen
so viel verloren grünen Chef nuripur
räumt im ZDF sommerin
erhoffte Eintracht statt Berliner
Dauerstreit um mit nuripur auf
Heimaturlaub in seinem Wahlkreis in
Frankfurt Sachsenhausen im Herbst wird
hier in Hessen gewählt die bundesgrün
allerdings machen es den Wahlkämpfern
gerade schwer das ist richtig dass
zurzeit nicht besonders viel Rückenwind
kommt von von Berlin gerade für unsere
Landesverbände es ist aber auch nicht
zwingen so dass es von vorne frontal
letzten Sturm gibt ich habe ganz andere
Wahlkämpfe schon erlebt erlebt hat die
Partei gerade einen starken Absturz von
26 % im letzten Sommer auf 16 % jetzt
Grund auch eine Serie politischer
Niederlagen filzvorwürfe in Robert
habecks Wirtschaftsministerium und der
lange und noch nicht beendete Streit ums
heizungsgesetz ich habe noch nie erlebt
dass er Gesetze vier Monate erstmal
Streit brauchen bis man die überhaupt
ins Parlament bringt damit sie
verbessert werden können und ich wünsche
nicht nur dieser sondern auch künftige
Regierungen dass sich solche Prozesse
nicht wiederholen
aufregerthemen verfolgen die Ampel auch
in die Sommerpause wie etwa die
Pöbeleien und Ausschreitungen in
Berliner Freibädern der neue
CDU-Generalsekretär Linnemann fordert
heute mittags festnehmen abends vor den
Richter auch nuripur will diese
schnelleren Verfahren glaubt aber nicht
an die Machbarkeit wäre super nur fehlt
hat das Personal dafür und das fehlt
auch bei der Polizei und wenn ich das
richtig sehe haben die letzten Jahre die
schwarzen Sheriff in diesem Land so
viele Polizeistellen abgebaut dass die
Polizei über 20 Millionen Überstunden
eingehäuft hat heute Abend beginnt Nuri
pur seine politische Sommertour
Hauptthema dabei innere Sicherheit
starker Staat die Grünen auf der Suche
nach Gewinner Themen
das ganze ZDF soll man Interview mit
nuripur sehen Sie direkt nach und
immer mehr Menschen im Rentenalter sind
auf Hilfe vom Sozialamt angewiesen das
berichtet die Funke Mediengruppe mit
Bezug auf noch unveröffentlichte Zahlen
des Statistischen Bundesamts so hätten
im ersten Quartal 684
000 Menschen Grundsicherung im Alter
bezogen rund 15% mehr als im Vorjahr ein
Grund für den Anstieg sei die zunehmende
Zahl von Leistungsberechtigten aus der
Ukraine
die EU zahlt Tunesien viel Geld damit
das Land weniger Migranten nach Europa
lässt auf ein entsprechendes Abkommen
haben sich kommissionspräsidentin von
der Leyen und Tunesiens Präsident said
in Tunis gerade geeinigt über das
nordafrikanische Land kommen aktuell die
meisten Migranten aus Afrika nach Europa
von der Stadt Fax aus sind es bis zur
italienischen Insel Lampedusa rund 130
km über das Mittelmeer warum ist dieses
Abkommen heikel Florian neuhahn
erstmal ist es ein wichtiger Baustein
der neuen restriktiven
Flüchtlingspolitik der Europäischen
Union viele EU-Regierungen stehen ja
unter großem innenpolitischen Druck
wollen eben die Zahl der ankommenden
Flüchtlinge daher deutlich senken
deshalb ist es jetzt ein wichtiger
Baustein dass man mit den
Herkunftsländern den ausreiseländern wie
Tunesien zusammenarbeitet Europa will
bis zu 1 Milliarde Euro zahlen damit
Tunesien eben die Rolle des
grenzwächters sozusagen übernimmt etwas
ähnliches hatte man bereits 2016 mit der
Türkei unter Präsident Erdogan gemacht
aber diesmal schließt man einen Deal mit
einem Präsidenten der sich noch sehr
viel weiter von europäischen Werten
verabschiedet hat als eben Erdogan
diesmal ist es der tunesische Präsident
Kais als
pardon der seit Monaten gegen
Flüchtlinge im eigenen Land massiv hetzt
und vor allem auch dessen
Sicherheitsdienste erst diese Woche zum
Beispiel hunderte von Migranten in der
Wüste aussetzten ohne Hilfe und ohne
Wasser aber Europa scheint bereit hier
beide Augen zuzudrücken
um sich selbst eines Problems zumindest
ein bisschen zu entledigen danke schön
für diese Informationen aus Brüssel
Florian
die Zukunft des getreideabkommens
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine bleibt
ungewiss es läuft morgen aus viele
Staaten sind auf Lieferungen aus der
Ukraine angewiesen die UNO und die
Türkei vermitteln unsere
reporter-dessa umgehört
über 500 Tage Krieg liegen hinter den
ukrainischen Bauern vor ihnen endlose
Hektar Getreidefelder doch das
getreideabkommen das den Export über die
Häfen im schwarzen meerriegelt läuft in
der Nacht zum Dienstag aus Russland hat
eine Verlängerung bisher nicht
zugestimmt Bauer Valerie sieht das
gelassen
ich denke dass der getreidekorridor
weiter funktionieren und offen bleiben
wird
es ist doch so wenn die Ukraine kein
Getreide verkaufen kann dann wird es
eine Ernährungskrise in der Welt geben
wir sind kein so großes Land aber wie
ernähren dafür viele Länder
[Musik]
in der Erntezeit haben die Bauern auch
noch weitere Sorgen der Getreidepreis
ist seit Kriegsbeginn um die Hälfte
gefallen jünger und Diesel hingegen
wurden teurer und es fehlen
Arbeitskräfte allein hier aus dem Bezirk
beresan sind über 200 junge Männer von
der ukrainischen Armee eingezogen worden
mein Sohn ist 22 Jahre alt und er dient
in der Armee er wird immer mein kleines
Kind bleiben jeden Tag mache ich mir um
ihn sorgen
vielleicht sind es einfach diese großen
Sorgen um Leben und Tod weshalb sich die
Bauern in beresan von dem auslaufenden
getreideabkommen nicht verrückt machen
lassen außerdem eine Verlängerung der
Vereinbarung ist weiterhin möglich
allerdings muss Russland einverstanden
sein
seit Wochen protestieren in Israel
10.000 Menschen immer wieder gegen die
geplante Justizreform der Regierung auch
gestern Abend allein in Tel Aviv gingen
laut israelischen Medien 150.000
Demonstranten auf die Straße mit der
Reform sollen die Befugnisse des
Obersten Gerichts eingeschränkt werden
die Demonstranten sehen dadurch die
Unabhängigkeit der Justiz und die
Demokratie gefährdet
sengende Hitze in den USA am 16 Tag in
Folge stiegen die Temperaturen in
Phoenix Arizona auf über 43 Grad auch in
Südeuropa kündigt sich schon die nächste
Hitzewelle an seit gestern Morgen
wüteten auf der spanischen Insel La
Palma Feuer mehr als 4000 Menschen
wurden deswegen in Sicherheit gebracht
inzwischen erleichtern die
Wetterbedingungen die Löscharbeiten
die Schauspielerin und Sängerin Jane
Birkin ist tot weltberühmt wurde sie
1969 mit einem Chanson der ein
gesungener Liebesakt war
[Musik]
der Song im Duett mit sergeance Buch ein
Skandal ein Welterfolg er begleitete die
gebürtige Engländerin ein Leben lang
doch sie war auch Schauspielerin und
wirkte in mehr als 50 Filmen mit im
Alter von 76 Jahren starb Jane Birken in
Paris
jetzt zum Sport und da gab es heute
sogar zwei WM-Medaillen für die
deutschen Schwimmer echt beeindruckend
glänzender WM Einstieg in Fukuoka Japan
auch für die Männer Florian Wellbrock
gewinnt Gold über die 10 km im
Freiwasser Oliver Clement Bronze und
beide sichern sich die Olympia tickets
zum Schluss ein Solo des Favoriten
Florian Wellbrock hat 18 Sekunden
Vorsprung herausgeschwommen gut eine
Stunde 50 Minuten zuvor haben ihn noch
51 Konkurrenten zeitgleich begleitet in
26 Grad warme Wasser der Fukuoka Bucht
die 10 km aufgeteilt in 6 Runden mit der
Möglichkeit der Flüssigkeitsaufnahme
wovon er routiniert Gebrauch macht auf
der letzten Runde steigert Wellbrock das
Tempo der ungarischewski kann da nicht
mehr mithalten ebenso wenig wellbrox
Trainingskollege Oliver klemet der sich
aber über Bronze und Olympiastadt Platz
in Paris Freunde darf
sich nachher zu lösen aber ich bin
unheimlich stolz dass ich das heute im
Olymp Clement aus Podium geschafft habe
wir beides Olympia-Ticket gelöst haben
also das war das wichtigste Rennen auf
jeden Fall
und alle Ziele die ich mir gesetzt habe
sind erreicht worden also ungleich zu
viel nach der Goldmedaille durch Leonie
Beck gestern ein idealer Auftakt der WM
für die Deutschen freiwasserschwimmer
mit ihrem Aushängeschild Florian
Wellbrock
zweiter Podestplatz für Nicole
nikoleitzik bei den
parallelmeisterschaften in der
Leichtathletik in Paris nach Bronze über
100 Meter sprintete die 27-Jährige auch
über 200 Meter auf Platz 3 und sicherte
der deutschen Mannschaft die insgesamt 9
Medaille bei der Generalprobe für die
Paralympics 24
und noch zur Tour de France 15 Etappe
wieder in den Alpen mit Bergankunft im
Schatten des Montblanc Sieger nach knapp
180 km und steil im Schlussanstieg der
Niederländer baut Pools das spannende
Duell der Spitzenreiter geht unverändert
weiter Jonas weniger bleibt in gelb 10
Sekunden vor Tade pokercha und morgen
ist dann ein Ruhetag haben Sie sich
verdient danke schön wir haben noch den
Wetterbericht morgen gibt es im
Nordwesten und Westen Schauer am
Alpenrand auch Gewitter sonst ist es
trocken und zeitweise sonnig Höchstwerte
21 bis 30 Grad
so viel von uns um 9:45
Journal das gesamte heute Team wünscht
einen guten Start in die neue Woche hier
kommt jetzt das ZDF sommerinterview mit
grünen Chef nur Rico